Wie bitte?
Wie kann das sein?
Das Weltraumteleskop der ESA, der Europäischen
Weltraumagentur, Gaia jetzt Daten ermittelt,
die zeigen, dass unse Milchstraße eine Galaxie
aus zwei Galaxien ist.
Denn unsere Galaxie hat eine ganz besondere
Eigenschaft und die hat Gaia jetzt ermittelt
und das Ergebnis ist wirklich mindblowing!
Warum wir also in zwei Galaxien leben?
Jetzt in Clixoom Science & Fiction Bei uns
gibt es täglich Science Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal, denn nur dann verpasst
ihr kein Video!
Herzlich willkommen!
Das ist eine wirklich unglaubliche Erkenntnis.
Unsere Galaxie, unsere Milchstraße besteht
aus zwei Galaxien.
Und das hat die Astronomie jetzt wirklich
überrascht.
Bisher ging die Astronomie davon aus, dass
vielleicht ein paar kleine Satellitengalaxien,
also sehr kleine Gebilde mit unserer Milchstraße
verschmolzen sind.
Doch diese Vermutung war ein Irrtum.
Jetzt hat ein Forschungsteam von der Universität
Groningen in den Niederlanden den Beweis für
einen riesigen kosmischen Crash gefunden.
Rund 30.000 untersuchte Sterne sind nämlich
ganz anders als alle anderen Sterne in der
Galaxie.
Sie bewegen sich entgegengesetzt zu einem
großen Teil der Sterne und auch ihre chemische
Zusammensetzung ist anders.
Und das wirklich irre daran.
Sie haben sehr ähnliche Eigenschaften.
Und 13 Kugelsternhaufen mit den gleichen Eigenschaften
hat das Forschungsteam auch noch im Halo der
Milchstraße gefunden, also dem riesigen kugelförmigen
Bereich rund um die Scheibe unserer Galaxie.
Der Schluss des Teams: Diese Sterne und Sternenenhaufen
im Halo stammen alle aus der gleichen Galaxie,
und zwar nicht aus unserer Heimatgalaxie.
Amina Helmi aus dem Team dazu: „Wir haben
im Halo Sterne von verschmolzenen Satellitengalaxien
erwartet.
Was wir nicht erwartet haben, ist, dass die
meisten Halo-Sterne tatsächlich gemeinsam
aus einer großen Verschmelzung stammen."
Bisher war der festen der Wissensstand der
Astronomie, dass sich dort draußen Reste
von Zwerggalaxien befinden würden, aber das
dort gleich eine ganze Galaxie zu finden ist,
darüber sind jetzt alle überrascht.
Das Team hat weiter recherchiert.
Offenbar gab es vor 10 Milliarden Jahren einen
riesigen Crash zwischen unserer Milchstraße
und einer anderen Galaxie, woraus sich dann
unsere Galaxie in der heute bekannten Form
bildete.
Denn auch das konnte das Forschungsteam ermitteln.
Die Milchstraße ist nämlich nicht überall
eine dünne Scheibe.
In der Mitte ist sie zehnmal dicker.
Bisher war völlig unklar warum.
Simulationsrechnungen zeigen jetzt, dass dieser
dicke Teil durch den Crash wesentlich mit
verursacht worden ist.
Und wahrscheinlich erklärt er auch das mysteriöse
Flattern der Galaxie.
Sie tut das nämlich in Nord-Südrichtung,
also senkrecht zu ihrer Drehachse beziehungsweise
parallel.
Bisher ging man davon aus, dass der Durchgang
kleinere Galaxien diese Bewegung ausgelöst
hatten.
Diese Bewegung wäre nach den neuesten Erkanntnissen
dann noch quasi das Nachschwingen des Crashs.
Damals drang die Fremde Galaxie dann von oben
oder unten in die Milchstraße ein und beulte
sie erst in die eine Richtung aus.
Durch Gravitation wurde sie zurückgezogen
und beulte die Galaxie in die andere Richtung
aus.
Grund also für den dickeren Bereich in der
Mitte unserer Galaxie und dieses Nachschwingen.
Allerdings ist das noch reine Spekuklation
und es gibt noch keine Forschungen dazu.
Aber es ist ein beeindruckend klares und einleuchtendes
Bild.
Wir sind gespannt was Gaia noch so alles herausfinden
wird bei der Kartierung unserer Galaxie, aber
das war ja schonmal ein absoluter Hammer.
Abonniert unbedingt unseren englischen Kanal
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Nur verpasst ihr garantiert gar nichts.
Denn dort gibt es genauso Videopremieren,
wie hier auf dem deutschen Kanal.
Und hier geht es mit einem englischen Video
weiter: What existed before the Big Bang!
Stay tuned, see you soon!